tremendous changes lie ahead
tremendous ebbs and flows of the
political tide
before the general trend is established
the general trend is not yet established
what we
are experiencing now is the cracking up
of the previous uniform cultural myth
and turbulence syncretism
cults confusion it's not dissimilar to
the crack up of the roman world and the
rise of
the gnostic and ortho and
mystery cults that flourished at that
time
there is the general consensus is that
there is not a general consensus
and this sets up a situation of extreme
high energy with the potential for
crystallization
in a new direction so we are
i think share the position of relativism
in the matter
of what is true and untrue
the best myths will empower themselves
to become
realities the notion of memes
of competing linguistic and ideational
uh gene-like units
that seek to perpetuate themselves and
overwhelm
competitors and make symbiotic
relationships with similar ideas and
trade
genetic material or informational
material around
is i think a very fruitful one and it
would lead to a very negative conclusion
if we were to look at it through the
eyes of darwinian mechanism
but we now know that that's false that's
wrong
the word the biological world doesn't
work
through maximizing competitive
difference
the natural world the truly successful
strategy
is the one that maximizes
interdependence and cooperation
if an animal species can make itself
absolutely necessary to the survival of
yet another animal species
it gains the energy as it were the
loyalty
of that other organic engine
of self perpetuation so
the real way the real strategy to get
ahead in the biological world is to have
as many friends as possible
as many organisms needing your presence
either to pollinate or to provide uh
biological byproducts or
to change the ph of
of material coming out of the soil
as in the mycorrhizal relationships of
fungi to the
to the roots of trees so this
in the human world what will uh
metaphorically realize this kind of
thing
is a dissolving of boundary conditions
and we've talked a lot during the week
about
gender-slanted societies dominator and
partnership
societies this sort of thing but i
want to reiterate that to my mind
uh you know if you walk around on two
legs
you are extremely yang
and the dichotomy is between the
vegetable
and the animal world feminism
the great goddess is the vegetable
mantle
of regulatory and uh
who knows what else processes
called self-cognition self-awareness
perhaps
that uh enshrouds the planet
when we shy
from that when we pull away from it and
become alienated and retreat into cities
or pastoralism or other adaptive modes
which allow us to hold the great goddess
at a distance then the tumorous growth
of ego begins because ego is essentially
a vidya ignorance it can only grow
in the presence of delusion and the
delusion
is the delusion of individuality
and separateness and apartness
and that delusion is sustained by
avoiding the sources of gnosis which are
the vegetable mysteries the shamanic
pathways
and society fault if it falls into
if a bifurcation occurs such that it
takes the path
of falling into a position of retreat
from that if it defines it as quote
unquote in the old
vocabulary chaos in other words
that which is dissolving threatening
unpredictable
and suffocating then progressively
more and more neurotic cultural barriers
will be
erected against this and
more and more cock-eyed cosmogonic myths
will be created ending in something like
modern science where you know you can
measure
the density of aluminum in a star
30 light years away but you can't
get along with the guy you share your
office with
because he's such a mystery to you that
it just drives you into
a lather when you attempt to deal with
them
so what is what is needed is uh
models of process that are
close to home fractalized
democratized if you wish it's not enough
to live in a hierarchical society
where you don't understand what's going
on but you have
faith that somewhere in laboratories
in corporate boardrooms and government
halls
somebody understands it because somebody
else understanding it is not
operationally effective for you
so part of the notion of the time wave
and of the tao
and of fractals generally i think is a
re-empowering of
local domain you know local
in all senses of the word meaning your
community
your house yourself
re-empowering the local domain and
stepping away
from these uh paternalistic
dominator of
hierarchies and elites because it is a
complete
disempowering of the individual to buy
into this
[Music]
you